je sens pénétrant dans mon cerveau comme
une pieuvre c'est à dire plusieurs
tentacules qui
occupent mon cerveau c'est un peu le
sentiment que j'ai eu j'ai tout de suite
compris que l'un des gars que je
recevais était très probablement en
représentant de cette race
d'extraterrestre qui vit parmi nous
bonjour je m'appelle Jean-Claude Bourret
j'ai 50 ans un peu plus de cartes de
presse professionnelle numéro 24606 j'ai
commencé ma carrière à France Inter
ensuite j'ai créé France 3 puisque j'ai
fait le 1er journal télévisé le 1er
janvier 1973 et j'ai terminé ma carrière
comme rédacteur en chef fait directeur
des stations régionales de Radio Monte
Carlo à Paris et à Monaco alors les
ovnis évidemment j'ai un peu cette
étiquette bourré les ovnis comment tout
cela a-t-il commencé bien cela
commençait quand j'étais tout petit je
devais avoir 6 ans 5-6 ans j'ai été
confronté à deux petites boules
métalliques que j'ai vu comme ça un peu
par hasard en jouant et j'ai ressenti
une peur absolument énorme que je
ressens encore
et j'ai analysé plus tard que cette peur
n'était pas naturelle on peut avoir peur
quand quelqu'un nous fait peur dans un
couloir qui s'éteint brusquement et puis
vous avez quelqu'un qui sort et puis qui
fait ou là on a une peur ça dure une
demi seconde mais après on dit arrête
tes bêtises alors est-ce qu'il y a des
extraterrestres parmi nous alors je me
baserai sur deux ou trois déclarations
de personnalité éminentes qui sont pas
des imbéciles et bien l'affaire de Turin
ça se passe en plein jour c'est d'abord
le radar de Turin le radar de l'aéroport
qui détecte quelque chose qui est assez
proche de l'axe d'atterrissage des
avions donc il y a un danger potentiel
donc il demande par radio est-ce que
vous voyez quelque chose parce que moi
j'ai un décor radar et les gars disent
les pilotes oui on voit une boule
lumineuse
bon alors il y a un avion d'Air France
qui voit ça un avion de l'Italia qui
décolle qui voit ça un Piper aztèque
c'est à dire un bimoteur à hélice qui
entend les conversations échangées entre
la tour de contrôle et les deux avions
avec des équipages de pilotes
professionnels aguerri et qui dit si
vous voulez moi je peux m'approcher de
cette chose pour essayer de savoir ce
que c'est alors point important il y
avait un vent d'environ 30 à 40 km/h à
cette altitude un kilomètre et demi à
peu près et cette boule lumineuse ne
bougez pas donc elle résistait avant
c'était donc pas un ballon sandre ou un
nuage ou je ne sais quoi et quand
l'avion le Pipper aztèque s'est approché
de la boule à 400 km/h puisqu'il s'est
mis en léger piqué comme ça et bien la
boule est partie et l'avion a été laissé
sur place dans le gouvernement russe on
retrouve ça aussi sur le web le
président Medvedev celui qui a succédé
aux deux premiers mandats de Poutine
avant de lui laisser à la place pour X
mandat et bien le Président medvedef il
a été filmé sans s'en rendre compte par
un journaliste à la sortie d'une
interview qui venait de donner à la
télévision russe et il y a une
journaliste qui qui lui pose une
question sur les objets volants non
identifié il dit mais est-ce que vous y
croyez vous qui êtes bien renseigné
monsieur le Président que faut-il en
penser et alors il dit bah écoutez voilà
la première chose quand on est élu
président de la Russie c'est qu'on nous
donne une mallette et dans cette
mallette il y a la liste de tous les
extraterrestres qui sont dans tous les
gouvernements du monde et là la
journaliste qui pose cette question or
antenne comme ça
dans un coin du studio elle est morte de
rire parce qu'elle se dit se moque de
moi quand on regarde benveneff il est
très sérieux vous ajoutez à ça les
déclarations d'un ancien ministre de la
Défense canadien qui est mort il y a
quelques années quand il était mis à la
défense canadien il a eu accès au
dossier objet volant non identifié et il
dit très clairement dans un certain
nombre de vidéos que vous retrouverez
sur le web vous tapez ministre canadien
défense OVNI vous allez trouver ces
vidéos ces livres également et vous
verrez que c'est pas char d'attan c'est
quelqu'un qui est extrêmement bien
renseigné et qui dit la même chose voilà
j'ai interviewé le ministre français de
la Défense il y a 50 ans
qui m'a parlé des ovnis et non pas pour
me dire écoutez il y a rien dans le
dossier des militaires français il m'a
dit exactement l'inverse on le trouve
dans un de mes premiers livres qui
s'appelle
OVNI l'armée parle je crois ou oui ou la
nouvelle vague des soucoupes volantes
enfin je me suis un peu exactement mais
c'est les tous premiers livres que j'ai
écrit il y a l'interview de ce ministre
des tâches chargé de la défonce
nationale Monsieur Robert Gallet et
quand je suis allé le voir dans son
bureau au ministère de la Défense et
qu'il m'a reçu il y avait sur son bureau
à peu près 200 rapports que je voyais à
l'envers je voyais les cacher rouge très
secret confidentiel secret des forces
c'était tous les rapports d'OVNI que
déjà à l'époque nous étions dans les
années 75 74 74 même
que l'armée française avait recueilli
depuis la fin de la deuxième guerre
mondiale alors des histoires
extraordinaires comme ça qui n'ont ni
que ni tête c'est-à-dire pour celui qui
découvre à l'instant où je parle de
dossier il dit mais qu'est-ce que c'est
que ces histoires tout ça c'est vraiment
des des inventions c'est ce sont des
grands malades oui au début moi c'est ce
que je croyais mais c'est la vérité
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise d'autre je présentais le journal de
20h de TF1 c'était un week-end je sors
du maquillage il était 8h moins une à
peu près je vais vers mon siège de
présentateur et je me souviens que
j'avais deux invités et au moment où je
sors du maquillage je sens pénétrant
dans mon cerveau comme une pieuvre c'est
à dire plusieurs tentacul es qui qui
occupent mon cerveau c'est un peu le
sentiment que j'ai eu et j'ai tout de
suite compris j'étais très calme très
cool j'ai tout de suite compris que l'un
des gars que je recevais était très
probablement un représentant de cette
race d'extraterrestre qui vit parmi nous
alors qui c'était et bien ça a été
effacé pourtant il est assez facile de
savoir qui s'était puisque en 13 ans de
présentateur du journal de TF1 je n'ai
reçu d'hommes politiques dans un journal
de 20h du week-end que très très peu
peut-être une dizaine ou une quinzaine
je me souviens plus exactement mais très
très peu donc c'est assez facile de
prendre tous les journaux de 20h de
janvier 1975 à juin 1987 où j'ai quitté
TF1 pour aller créer l'information sur
la 5 et de voir quels sont les hommes
politiques que j'ai reçus et parmi ces
hommes politiques il y en a un qui avait
ou des pouvoirs extraordinaires que je
n'ai jamais connu ni jamais entendu
parler tout au long de ma longue vie ou
alors c'est ce que je pense c'était un
représentant extraterrestre sur la
planète Terre alors pourquoi face à une
civilisation extraterrestre nous sommes
partagés entre deux tendances la
première tendance qui est une partie de
l'humanité c'est de dire ce sont nos
frères du cosmos accueillons-les à bras
ouverts la deuxième tendance c'est de
dire j'ai peur je ne sais pas ce que
c'est que ces êtres qui sont pas du tout
d'origine humaine et qui sont
certainement hostiles donc comme le
disait dans le cinquième élément un
militaire qui était auprès du président
de l'époque qui était le président de la
Confédération elle disait moi je tire
d'abord je discute ensuite donc il y
aura toujours ces deux tendances aller
vers l'autre pour essayer de le
comprendre ou tuer l'autre parce qu'il
est pas comme vous donc l'humanité a
toujours fonctionné comme ça une petite
lumière qui se balade dans le ciel ça
n'a aucun intérêt ça peut être un
satellite ça peut être n'importe quoi
mais quand vous avez quelqu'un comme
Monsieur masse qui est dans le sud de la
France qui est un agriculteur qui a 6
heures du matin va labourrer son champ
et puis il voit dans son champ de
lavande ce qui prend d'abord pour une
voiture parce qu'il est à 300 mètres ça
ressemble un peu à une Dauphine pour
ceux qui connaissent les voitures
anciennes donc c'est un peu arrondi des
deux côtés comme ça avec une sorte de
cabine au milieu et donc il s'approche
il dit mais ça c'est un Parisien qui a
dû rouler dans mon champ de lavande
c'est pas possible il s'approche au fur
et à mesure qu'il s'approche et se rend
compte que c'est pas une Dauphine que
cette chose qui fait à peu près 4,5
mètres de diamètre et 2 m ou 3 m de
hauteur elle est posée sur des pieds
comme ça qui s'enfoncent dans son sol de
lavande et il y a deux petits bonhommes
qui sont penchés sur un plan de lavande
il continue à s'approcher il comprend
pas il a aucune espèce dans sa mémoire
d'image lui permettront de dire ça c'est
probablement ça au début il a cru que
c'était des touristes avec une voiture
une Dauphine et puis là il est incapable
de dire mais ce que je vois qu'est-ce
que c'est les deux bonhommes se
redressent ils font un mètre 10 à peu
près ils ont une grosse tête
l'un des ils sont vécu d'une sorte de
combinaison grise l'un des deux petits
bonhommes gris prend un tube creux à son
côté le dirige sur monsieur masse qui
instantanément et paralysé il peut plus
bouger mais il garde son équilibre
il peut plus parler les deux petits
bonhommes remontent dans l'ovni l'ovni
d'école
les espèces de de barres qui lui
permettait de tenir sur la lavande se
rétracte et l'ovni par à toute vitesse
monsieur masse évidemment est stupéfait
il retrouve l'usage de ses membres au
bout d'une dizaine de ministres et il va
pas labourrer son champ il est tellement
bouleversé parce qu'il a vécu parce que
là il comprend qu'il est face à quelque
chose d'extraordinaire il va au bar de
son petit village c'est un ami de longue
date qui tient le bar et il lui raconte
ce qui vient de vivre et lui dit surtout
tu n'en parle à personne c'était la
meilleure façon pour que tout le village
soit au courant la gendarmerie est au
courant elle vient voir Monsieur masse
dès le lendemain matin elle va sur place
elle prend les mesures parce qu'il y a
des traces tout à fait significatives la
lavande ne poussera pas ne repoussera
plus dans un rayon d'environ 10 mètres à
l'endroit où l'ovnis s'est posé moi j'ai
rencontré Monsieur masse d'ailleurs
quelques années plus tard il m'avait il
voulait voir personne mais comme je
présentais le journal de 20h de TF1 à
une époque où il n'y avait que le
journal de 20h de TF1 pratiquement et
bien il avait accepté de me recevoir il
était très gentil avec sa femme etc et
il m'a dit je ne peux pas tout vous dire
ça m'a intrigué je ne peux pas tout vous
dire alors qu'est-ce qu'il a gardé pour
lui jusqu'à sa mort j'en sais rien ce
qui est sûr c'est ce qu'il a vécu est
absolument incompréhensible mais c'est
très très loin d'être unique en France
et dans le monde vous avez des tas de
gens qui ont vécu ça certains n'en n'ont
jamais parlé
d'autres en ont parlé mais les
journalistes ont dit bon c'est un fou
c'est un alcoolique comme si le fait
d'être
ivre mort faisait voir des objets
volants en identifié des petits
extraterrestres on est confronté à
quelque chose qu'on ne veut pas voir